[Music]
delighted to have you guys here
thank you the the experience last night
of the Creek was transcendent it was
incredible and I'd seen lots of videos
of you guys performing and you know
listen to obviously you know digital
recordings of your music but it didn't
really prepare me for the experience of
what you could you guys do before a live
audience
it's really amazing and to see you carry
and hold such a powerful vibration I
remember just kind of canvassing the
audience and looking out at everybody
just so fixated and impacted by the
beautiful art that you guys put out in
the world thank you thank you yeah it's
uh it's cool to have you guys here today
thank you form a little bit we're
opening up the format which I'm excited
about so I think you know what I'm
interested in hearing about you know
what you guys do is so different it
defies categorization it's you know it's
the result of so many different
influences so when somebody asks you
like how do you characterize your your
music like how do you answer that or
think about that well we have probably
two different answers here but in
[Laughter]
together together
now you're together but not together
yeah so but I think the way I see it we
come from my rock background we play we
used to play heavy metal and we did that
for many years we had bands gaff gende
my band later we come from a thrash
metal background and we still I mean we
love it but we always both we grew up
surrounded by yeah cool parents that
were listening to you know to different
styles and listen to jazz and and wasn't
no flamenco and you know and so I guess
when we left Mexico City in 1999
and we went to Ireland all these
influences I mean we left heavy metal a
little bit behind and then we only
carried two acoustic guitars and I think
all these influences just just came came
up in Rylan out of nowhere and just a
mix but I think it basically is rock
acoustic rock that's the way I would put
it yeah Gabriella
you said you disagree agree well it's an
interesting story because you begin in
Mexico City but then you're in Ixtapa
for a while right together before you go
to Dublin yeah so you have this band
experience there so what motivated you
to say like we're gonna go we're gonna
pick up and go to Europe what I think it
was a mix of things at that time when we
had the band em it was this metal band
we wanted to sound like Metallica it
Sepultura Testament and all those say
usually Slayer the usual suspects of
metal and and for us we would had this
illusion of do bake with a band and all
of these things and I used to play the
electric guitar with the with the
Marshalls and rod played the other
guitar and scream a little and then his
brother played the bass and I had a
friend played the drum so we were like a
proper met on the ground and so we
couldn't really do play much it was we
were internationally non famous and a
struggle to to make it and also we we
worked in another in another works like
I used to teach some classes to kids and
I teach them like Metallica race or
something like this to make some more
money and
rather I think he worked in a TV station
doing music and then at some point we
said you know it's just limitlessly
yeah for us it was at least it Mexico
City was so big
it's so big and it's for some people we
don't like CDs anyway whatsoever but
nevertheless Mexico's it is 25 million
people yeah livin there soon and it was
it was quite a big thing and for me was
like oh what the beach is just like a
few hours of waiting years and then
because me and Rodrigo we always jam
with it with the acoustic guitars we'll
always jam into different not just metal
music we love tour guitar music so a lot
of people said ah were like my auntie's
you know they said why do you don't play
bad instead cuz it sounds nicer you know
quit the acoustic and we can go to
Ixtapa and play for like auntie's and
just like tourists and play this mellow
acoustic guitar and save some money and
go to Europe so we reset our definition
of success at that time but we started
playing like Slayer tunes in acoustic we
having a material so right you know we
had to play back three hours in the
hotels you know how stuff like that so
we said well we need to just start just
doing this metal acoustic metal tunes
right and hey I mean the Theresa that's
the interesting Mexican I think you'd be
really cool because it would be very
different but also recognizable for
somebody's like not all Canadians you
know they were not that familiar with
Slayer uh-huh and so we kind of got away
with it right but the idea was we're
gonna go here and we're we're done with
taking a paycheck anywhere like no
matter what we're gonna earn our living
playing music we're gonna live as lean
as possible as minimal
as possible so that we can commit a
hundred percent yes so we what sir we
said everything we said okay now our
definition of success for us would be
play guitar and keep learning musically
speaking and in travel travel the world
in a start in Europe but before to you
we for Europe we need to take some money
so we went to except one that said we
started to to think ok we can play in
the hotel's in the lobbies and we can
and the restaurant and then we can save
money and not everything works a little
like whoa cuz everybody says no no no no
I could went to it like at least 30
hotels and they all say no but at some
point one guy said a pizza guy he owns a
pizzeria there he said ok come that
counts but I can't pay you but you can
play and you can put like the tips he
gave was wine and pizza for free so and
you're at the beach already yes yes so
happy and we went to Lucas a lot of
people saw us like the hotel so it was
all these two guys are playing these
crazy well no it wasn't like crazier the
terminal was just like they want us for
the wedding so we will start playing
weddings and they look cocktail parties
and sewed all of that so we became super
busy and we didn't save money until the
last month before we went to you but I
like how you redefine success in your
own terms right it doesn't have to be a
record contract or playing on it like
last night it was just we're at the
beach we don't have jobs we're making a
living playing music we're committed to
mastering our craft and like that is
success yeah yeah small victories that
you really need I mean probably at the
time we didn't I mean weren't aware of
these small victories but we we knew we
wanted just to play guitar yeah and at
some point after quitting the band
and we was like doesn't matter if we
play in a coffee or music way I'm not
gonna be like selling swimming suits you
know I prefer to play guitar and that's
nothing wrong with those kind of jobs
but I just wanted to play guitar and for
us to to stick to our guns
when we left except and went to Dublin
for like how that was kind of for the
same goal so like we're not going to do
anything else but playing music and we
never thought I mean with after nine
months of playing hotels we say okay
we're going to go to Dublin and find a
hotel or at least a pub but it doesn't
work like that yeah all about Grafton
Street quickly realize happy realize
that we had to plan streets yeah and it
was the best experience ever
well the busker culture there but I must
say that adding to the ready Phoenicians
of success the experience with the band
was quite intense because emotionally we
were grasping so much to to get things
like we were our own managers in our own
way and we took a room for it was like
the total is final and so with instead
of focusing on music and stuff we were
focusing on how can we play here how can
we do this and that drained drained us
that's why we we said not with we don't
like we can't quit music and as a matter
of fact now we're gonna embrace music
and that's how they we said okay
wherever we can go and play in anybody's
wedding anywhere else background music
whatever but for us every single note is
going to have a meaning you know and
that that was one once we just came
there and we didn't that the mistake
there was not a saving of money it was
not spending as much
fire I think there's something really
beautifully profound about that which is
this idea of letting go of results or
being results driven like hey we need to
like you know control this process so
that we go from here to this other place
and instead saying listen we just love
playing guitar and like how can we just
set our lives up so that we can play and
that's the wind and let go of trying to
control wherever this leads us and just
being in for wherever it's going to go
yeah because there's this this drive of
trying to control things for us in my
experience was the opposite came we
wanted so it was for a look at what
let's try not care about them see what
happen say you're you're you're in
Dublin and you're busking and you're on
Grafton Street and this is sort of like
correct me if I'm wrong but in my
imagination this is sort of like The
Beatles in in in Hamburg right like just
you're putting in your reps you're
playing every day all day long and over
time through that consistent process you
start to find your sound and this you
know this thing that's so identifiable
in what you do yes sorry the thing is we
were playing we're kind of doing the
same playing the same music we were
playing the hotels and like covers and
some time and Slayer and whatever but
and this is in Grafton Street but some
day this you know urge of just composing
writing your own music again but a
boyfriend metal you started to you know
to really really push us to do something
and then so we became we started writing
our own music they're like the first
versions of what you just heard
yesterday right like 20 years ago and
it's funny I mean when we played those
tunes that we were writing in
in our little room in Dublin on streets
people gave us more money
uh-huh and that that was you know the
the thing that made us write more not I
mean we were not looking for management
we're not looking for venues to play
because we're done with that yes a very
important fact that as you know we're a
skill some money wise wasn't very good
because we're just not so what we did
was when we came to Ireland there was
one way tickets where Ivan dope in April
4th of April 9 1991 9 and and then we we
had essentially will we run of 1000
sterling pounds in a week because we
were playing pain I don't remember
whether with the thing is and one week
after he had no money remember this
Mexican guy we met before we went it was
like oh oh by the way I live in Dublin I
mean call it it's in Mexico and Feroze
was like oh how quitted and she's
incredible unless she said really nicely
look when you arrive to Dublin I'm gonna
be in Poland you guys can stay in my
house and this is the direction said you
guys could stay 15 days so you need to
spend money in those 15 days you will
find another place to go wow life is
great University when the taxi Kasai
that taxi man was so nice he came and
took us to this house and we saw a note
and at the door and then the pen she
said oh there's no door
[Music]
so that's why you just yeah completely
and and then eventually it we run out of
this thousand sterling pounds because we
went to an agency I was crazy and the
thing was that we had this little car
that we're never used and I said okay
now with the power of the beginning say
present card so we put it into the ATM
machine and we said okay let's put six
hundred whatever and he just gave us
some money it was right it was an
advance exactly wasn't like we were oh
no we had to go and we had to play in
the Irish summer which is a winter and I
had to play in the street and there was
every time we just play in these crazy
in order to play that a stupid amount of
it was like you get a little cash every
day and you're getting instant feedback
on the music yeah you're putting out
yeah yeah yeah yeah in that sense I mean
and it's not Lee actually you make more
money I don't know now but back in the
day when we stopped busking and started
playing pops and coffee places we made
more money Expedia no III had a man a
Palmer on the podcast and I you know she
when she left you know she was a street
performer in Cambridge doing this
eight-foot pride thing and she was doing
really well and her Dresden Dolls
partner was like come on we got a tour
in the band and that was like a big pay
cut to like you know pursue music that
to her
[Laughter]
and she had to like think about it like
at first she didn't want to leave that
because it was a that was believe it or
not that was like security yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
so I think it's it's sort of reductive
to say I mean you know when I'm sure
people ask you all the time like well
what was your big break like what was
the moment where it kind of tipped into
a different gear and and and it seems
like one of those moments for you as a
reductive as it as it probably sounds
and the grand scheme of things was was
damien rice seeing you guys right and
taking an interest in what you were
doing I would imagine that that really
changed things
oh yes because that introduced us to you
know to venues proper venues he was he
had a band which it was successful too
like previous years before we arrived
like probably 97 and then he left a band
and he started his solo career I started
working on his big album right you know
and and he you know we were basking and
suddenly we saw this hippie guy just
sitting in front of us like can straight
see and and we became friends with him
yeah and and we did and he was building
his solo career he was actually afraid
of busking in Dublin because he he I
mean some people knew who he was because
of the band he was in so he would go to
her going and busk there because if they
saw him they would think he hit hard
exactly I don't know where he had his
reasons and then um so we were kind of
Celebi like living life in Europe while
he was working hard he went on tour he
was making like doing his own things
like going to Germany and secret gigs
here and there there you know and then
we decided to go away from Dublin for
six months we went to Denmark we're
basking in there my busking in Barcelona
went back to Ireland and then Damian was
already like with his new album it was
number one yeah and we ran into each
other in Tower Records like the old
record store and and he said like hey
I'm gonna play a show in Baker Street
you widget you want to just open for me
is it like great and that day
that baby came back to you they were met
Nile which is still managing that day I
mean he was working with Damian that
they split and now we met that night we
met our manager and we still with him
well that's amazing and so here you are
how many albums now five album for our
first studio first four and four studio
and and and three you played at the
White House
[Music]
because we didn't know it we were on
tour of course like a long long tour in
Australia and then at some point our
manager rang us today at the White House
round by office and they said I wanted
you guys to play there but then and I
didn't say anything because you're so
secret and all of this it was about okay
we immediately assume is gonna be a
party with some politicians and we're
gonna say yes and then it was the last
day of the tour and so well we arrived
in and in DC we were so jet lag so tired
so tired and had to get up even a dremel
which was her friend she travel with us
she fell to sleep for the first time in
years she never felt sleepy worried we
were that tired so when we arrived to
the White House and me Rodrigo just like
these nothing fancy we came in through
security and then these guys like men in
black too and they took us to this oh
come on come here do too and they took
us to the White House and they took us
to this crazy incredible place inside it
no this is the room this is like a
museum kind of thing and they left us in
a little room there like four maybe five
minutes just waiting waiting and then
they took us to this place where it was
full of photographers and then we just
step in it and I was president there and
Michelle Obama would say was like what
is of my dreaming cuz we were just like
oh hi Michelle
[Laughter]
rather than their to goodness hello
what's your name
and I said well my name is Gabriela
what's your good I mean they had this
thing celebrating something between
Mexicans and States but and then Beyonce
was playing half an hour uh and and we
were playing half an hour right but they
had built this beautiful stage outside
the White House
I know I'm I just like their music said
like the first thing said like I have
your music my iPod and even was using
some of the music and at the campaign
mmm and yeah he was he was a fan and he
loves music as you know and and and he
was it was great just to be there and we
perform half an hour than Beyonce
perform another half an hour it was
surreal like I just wanted to punctuate
that like that arc is so insane yeah you
know and when you're walking through a
public square whether it's in Europe in
the United States or in a subway station
and you see somebody busking it's very
easy to be dismissive like wow man you
know it must be hard for that person
maybe it is maybe it isn't but you don't
really think that the possibility exists
that you could transcend that like
paradigm yeah like what you guys get to
do now yeah and as you said like been on
the streets is so magical because he's
seen life through completely another
perspective because you are like almost
invisible and you are not playing any
role he just in the street we got a lot
of like really crazy experiences in the
streets and the even and I think we
dedicated what tune to a tune is called
Viking man
one homeless guy in Denmark and there
was this homeless guy that we considered
was like an angel because there was
police there was very strict and he
looked that policeman looked exactly
like that cartoon Top Cat
policeman it looked exactly the same and
he came like oh no you can't play this
for blah okay and they keep it might say
that he's not here and you know
sometimes we start arguing as we
normally did and then he came at you to
stop and play your no just scream at us
like this and and he was just taking
care of her ourselves in his own crazy
way cuz he was wrong and all of these
things and we felt like it's just
another dimension almost in the street
and it's also good for us nah it's never
gonna change the fact that you walked
into a street
I always looked and who is there and
just acknowledged no owner whoever even
if it's just somebody like it's so
wasted you know it's still a human being
right yeah and you can't be about
expectations it has to be about the love
of the music and just you know just
being present for whatever's gonna
happen exactly it was so sweet and cute
last night Gabriella like after you guys
you know came back out for the Encore
and you're like you're like okey-dokey
we're gonna play is it such a contrast a
power with which you play and the
ferocity and you're shaking your head
and you can't even see how fast your
hand is moving and it's just like I'm
like what is even happening and then
you're like
[Laughter]
I'm jamming light still won't win was
like these it's like this weird duality
I guess but when you're when you're up
there on stage and even just now when
you perform for us
I noticed you know you both like close
your eyes and it's almost like you're
entering this trance-like state when
you're playing and it feels more like
you're it's it's sort of beyond the
experience is beyond music in that it
feels like you're just transmitting like
a signal like an energy right like
there's a there's like you are a channel
for something that comes from the beyond
and you're there to transmit it yeah
yeah that's the intention I mean that is
intention and I think that happens
that's why music is mystical I mean it
that's why goddess it gathers people and
and and people go there to you know to
feel something right and when when we
started I don't think we were aware of
that power nowadays after many years of
touring and and there are some years of
struggle because there is a point you
know you at the beginning you are like
so like I'm gonna do this you don't even
know why you just feel something right
and then you get comfortable you know
you you just like two or three albums
and then you just make you know your
life is very comfortable right as a
musician it's a touring musician and you
hit a point when you've really kind of
forget that feeling of and then you have
to to meet it again you have to meet the
reason again you have to find it to look
for it because somewhere kind of you
just got lost you know and that happens
those like four years ago
we're in Japan and we were like
think you know we we've been just asleep
for the last photo you know yeah and we
kind of made a deal in Japan we're in
Japan so like let's let's get these
together we didn't know how let's get it
back and because we are like tour in the
same places playing for the same people
it's like it's good but well why are we
doing this you know and then is that
combined with personal experiences that
you need to transcend you see what you
feel like okay this is what I do best I
mean we have different interests but
music is the thing that we feel and how
can we use this to heal ourselves but
not only that but just to share
something the people to inspire people
to do something with it
that is really really really powerful
and nowadays we try to do it I mean we
have left a little bit of that ego thing
that is always there like thinking that
people is there for you it's not it's
not true you know I'm saying it's not
true and when you're on the stage these
days when we're on the stage we would
try to I mean we can play good some day
some of the days were more nervous some
of this but that doesn't really matter
and you know as long as you're tried to
be present and try to to connect with
them try to I mean we are energy for
sure I mean this is not I mean it
sounded like a few years ago it sounded
crazy but now you know science is
telling you you know different things
and all this new side like neurologists
are coming with different stories about
how we broadcast the signal right and
that's what I want to do every night I
would try to just to send to send stuff
and to share whatever it comes to me
that day and I think you're doing the
same yeah yeah when you came on stage
the first to open the the evening the
first thing you did was express
gratitude
yes you're saying I'm so grateful to be
able to be here tonight and not just me
like oh I'm you know the two of us get
to be up here but like how grateful how
amazing is that that it were just it's
this beautiful night or under the stars
with this
venue and we get to participate in music
that in and of itself right yeah like
back to the roots back to just pure
artistic expression yes yeah right and
and and the new album is called meta
evolution right so you got a chance to
kind of explain what that means
mm-hmm so talk to us about well would I
explain what's a meta is a Sanskrit word
for compassion and loving-kindness but
that this is the Western translation
apparently you speak Tibetan or Sanskrit
it has a more deeply meaning and and
everything and Volusia comes from
evolution so in our own world in our own
vision as an artist we wanted to
portrayed a vision of a world that whose
humanity and their talents and their and
their science and all their intelligence
is in service of life and and that is
possible but you need to practice this
is like this practice a skill and and
being compassionate and practice
compassion it takes it is a whole other
level you need to transform your person
you need to become someone else almost
because it's just meaning that you have
to face your fears and everything else
and also face the fact that we are not
perfect and sometimes we don't like to
see how bad we are
yeah no one likes to look at that know
it we can we can breathe about Oh my
family did this to me all have lots of
opinions about how everyone else can
change exactly but what about what am i
doing and that's what it is all about so
in my world is it take your own
responsibility and just expand the
circle of compassion you know just add
more let's include more that's the idea
right meta m ET t a which means loving
- there is a loving-kindness Metta
meditation technique I've had Sharon
Salzberg on the podcast
it's a beautiful practice it's a suit so
cool that you name your album that yes
and it's interesting because it's so
like at times the album so and it is
like it's like a trance like there's a
there's like a you can kind of it's a
trance-like thing it's almost like
mantra you know this is the way that
mantra works with meditation like it it
just puts you it changes your state yeah
nothing mantra when you hear all this
singing and crazy know all the Indian
music that raga
right-oh different tunings and it's just
like to me is like because every time
ago even like the yeah like if I hear
like practice I mean we women practicing
in Mara for years I mean I mean we do
different stuff I mean you you to
meditate yeah on the show over like I do
it for an hour every morning and every
night like I'm certainly not consistent
in that regard
do you know I iced I'm I started doing
meditation in 2004 with a like kind of
Buddhist teacher and since then I've
been practicing for some time I was
doing Metta and then recently I found
Joe Dispenza which is incredible and so
I mix I do Mara I I do the wind off
stuff aha which I love it yeah I do the
coal exposure and and the breathing and
and I practice a lot of the Joe Dispenza
stuff and I think you do some other
stuff as well right you practice a
modest discipline with what he once he
isn't something he does it would
represent to me what is very important
why do you meditate and why do you why
why do you want to be
it's almost sounds like super selfish
but the way we see it in the way we both
see it is like humanity is an instrument
so it's it's everyone tune itself it
would be tune that we might function
that's a a collective something and
that's the way I see it because
compassion is not just just going inward
and Narada I don't want to know about
any negativity in the world you have to
bring it into the world exactly in the
hard part because when you do things for
others and you get involved in an
activist work and in some sort of an arc
and he says you want to do good things
you're gonna face your own fears and
your ego projecting through other people
and that's why sometimes you can't go
forward you can't make the change
because you get sick of it on just like
oh those guys I hate them and then this
is like nothing is done yeah so you need
to work on your own self son in order to
when you go out out in the world you
actually do things you do you are
efficient in your own activism so I
think we all in my view we all should be
activists but before activists it's
important to do yeah you got to do that
first look at it's true in life and I
think it's reflected in your music like
the fact that you rod you know like
you're experimenting with all these
different practices I mean that's sort
of your sensibility around what you guys
do on stage right it's all of it's a
influence of all these different
influences you have a different you're a
hundred percent guy your emotional
Gemini person this like soup that
produces something magical and beautiful
and excuse me I think it's interesting
when people try to characterize
specifically what you do as like
flamenco like primarily flamenco or an
it because certainly there's a flair of
that but it's not that like it's
something totally year-round it is very
different it is flamenco is this an
incredible almost this again yes a
we lived in Spain and with we
knew incredible players incredible
people there you see people Wow we love
flamenco by the way but we're very
respectful flamenco so that's what we
said no we don't especially because we
know they hate when people confused
right oh they're like actually the
purist hate Paco de Lucia for instance
which is a god of flamenco guitar
because he experimented a lot and then
we have a friend resent amigo which is
genius and the way that's so what we do
is more rock and roll and I am I
developed a way to kind of play the
drums because we were on our own played
on the street and sometimes I felt
people who was gonna get bored which we
just play and so bateria stuff and like
scales and really nice arrangement to
true and then we answered a lot of
people it's gonna get bored they're like
oh you're not so firm it was important
to to keep the rhythm and I knew that
you can see flamenco or some mariachi or
some on other musics they do rhythms
with the hand and they break it it's not
like I invented it but I knew I didn't
know how to and my way to try to figure
out
it makes me discover new ones new way so
why this is like Coke I mean it is truly
percussive instrument as much as it is a
string instrument yeah you're Irish
that's because we used to have a friend
and it's sort of the Irish version yes
oh my god exactly yeah and then gap
music yes he told me a few moves and and
then because of our own place with a
stick that's the way they play it but I
practice it yeah yeah okay this ad Rome
is very beautiful music
we loved Irish music and so I started
practicing light like this like this and
a lot of the movements comes from that
technique instead of flamenco
[Music]
[Applause]
on stage the sound is so massive like
it's just the two of you yeah and you're
either playing electric or acoustic
you're playing acoustic but it sounds
like there's 15 instruments I mean like
how many inputs do you have like there
you have like mics inside they could
tell like how are you getting all these
different percussive sounds yes we do we
do I mean it's been a process in 2007
we're in Japan and Yamaha approaches and
and and and since then they've been
working with us and together and it's
great I mean we developed 12 years ago
which you couldn't find nylon string
guitars with piezo speeds are like
little microphone stick to the body of
the guitar mm-hmm besides that pick up
the normal pickle right you know and so
in order we were and we had at that time
we had toured Ireland and England and
ously and our profile had raised quite a
bit and then we hit a wall the day we
were invited to support Muse at their
first stadium shows in Wembley mmm so
our guitars were not for it you know and
we did it I was paying for Sony engineer
I mean I think that the venue was so
long it was so large you know and 80,000
people and and so we knew that we need
we needed to you know to upgrade the
whole thing and then we were using
different guitars and so we met Yamaha
and then we I mean this is nada and that
of course but yeah and it's the they
developed this system that wasn't
anywhere in the market back in the day
and and they've been just upgrading the
system and Gabriella has seven pieces in
the body because she plays all around
right so it so you turned one instrument
into seven basically well yeah or one
knowing where those pickups are places
all over the instrument recently it's
less it sounds very complex because the
system is very complex but as you when
we played here four instances two
microphones in two liters and that's the
essence of it so the ideas all that
sound how are you gonna bring the sound
to the level that fill that space
exactly 500 1000 people mm how are they
you as an engineer gonna bring this
level without feedbacks and more
distance so that's the development of
all these technologies and especially on
the guitars and that's why they we get
their little pesos which are like a peak
of the they captured the sound of the
wood and and that's the way it is I
don't know exactly
[Laughter]
well speaking of doing your thing you
know I mean what what's happening is I
mean when I was watching you it's this
is this is mastery of motion like you
guys are masters of your craft and you
know I'm sure no doubt it's the result
of you know years and years and years of
dedication to your craft
but there's something beautiful and just
transcendent about seeing a master at
work whether it's a basketball player or
a you know or anybody who's you know
kind of master their discipline so how
do you think about that like how do you
do you think do you even think about
that like no what I don't nothing yeah
not personally but you mean like
about out like tourists ourselves or
what like yeah I mean do you think leer
Li like you you want to be the best that
you can be right so what is the process
of doing that and like how do you think
about like becoming the best version of
what you can possibly be well not to at
least for me not to to Center everything
in I know the guitar thing is the the
thing that I have practiced the most and
probably because of that is one of the
things that I do better but I'm I was
never and the kind of guy that I wanted
to be the fastest or but you know and
now I think it's a whole thing
if I'm I feel if I meditate more if I
get to know myself better I'm gonna be
calmer when I'm on stage and that's
gonna probably gonna help to share more
information with others but that's one
part of me and I need to be more you
know to practice more in my compassion
towards my crew for example sometimes
you know and and so to me it's a whole
thing now I I want to become a better
person for for for the rests for the
people around me and not as an as a
single practice in this case the
musician you know itself and I you know
I try to do the best I can but always
try to you know to do something for for
the one this beside you and and try to
be good together which I spent a lot of
time with with my girlfriend back in
Mexico with my you know the people
around you you know and I learned a lot
from people like you when I listen when
I started listening to podcast like
three years ago you probably were you
know one of the first podcasts and
listening to your guests and your own
story your books and it's really
inspiring and and I think this thing
just passes from do to me from me to
others and and that's I think that's
that creates a better world
yeah
a master of your craft means to explore
mastery of self yes right in the
broadest sense but also is that this may
be code of your own you know when you
when you are been a little lazy or you
know when you are a little bit to push
it with yourself so it is to find that
balance and I think once you find that
balance is what you find
okay now I'm doing the best I can right
now
but sometimes for me and I think for you
too sometimes we had pushed ourselves
too badly or sometimes just not in I
think it is important to say okay I'm
not the most important person it doesn't
really matter you know if I play if I
made a mistake whatever doesn't matter
but what does matter is just to do
whatever you have to do around I'd like
at least I do i do meditate in my way I
like to run and so then on stage or when
we are playing together we are coming up
with new music you are at sharp you are
clear you are present because there's
nothing horrible to be like with like
hungry or like this like this trying to
come up with something and I think
that's the key to master something is
like you make sure your body and your
brain and your being is ready available
for this as you said like this resource
so that thing can come in yeah right
yeah yeah I'm doing that in in in the
worst place in step a be if you you know
if you are you play a match let's say a
soccer player and you you win 1000 then
you
I mean 10 oh I mean you don't really
learn much right yeah it's only when
you're tech and when you this and but
the thing is you need to be open to
those moments and you need to convince
yourself that you are going to learn
from the really dark
nights you know because if I mean you
get afraid but sometimes you get so many
of those nights at some points like well
you need to find a meaning you know to
those dark nights I mean those are those
can be gifts if you have the right
relationship problem is then you become
successful like you guys and you get
soft instead of like wait a minute like
what why are we doing this like where
are we finding our inspiration now
because life is easy yes oh but now I
need everything to be organic and like
blue what well I mean look you guys have
blazed of a fearless and very innovative
artistic life so what is the what is the
message that that you want the young
artist out there to hear somebody who is
struggling or trying to find their
identity or their path in an artistic
endeavor and I think it is very
important to keep yourself inspired all
the time and not be afraid to maybe look
at other artists also one thing that is
very important is metallic except
metallic but I think we've we're so
judgmental agriculture is so judgmental
it's so dismissive and so like that
that's crap Dusty's done and that's is
like a boom is like a boomerang it
adjusts compounds in this massive
insecurity and my god of great artists
in so talented people
I can't bring anything to the world
because they're so afraid they're gonna
treat them the same way they treat the
other people who've you know so and I
think one of the keys so I would say to
young people they want to play they want
to show they wanna it's like there's
always people they're not they not gonna
like what you do no matter what there's
always there those plans
those guys they're always gonna be there
you know I'm gonna focus on those but in
the other hand you have you can
potentially become better it bring
things to the to this world and they're
they're worthy for every everyone else
to see them so those fears that oh my
god am I good or I'm not good that comes
from the judgmental thing it is a bad
habit and it's always getting harder and
harder because social media that's what
I romance nation you know I see it in my
kids and it's it's it's debilitating
just leave the phone and just play
practice big I mean you know forget
about taking pictures for Instagram and
for you know rehearsal and just send it
to your I mean that doesn't really work
is really the maintaining people not
only I read the other day story in
England that young people like between
12 and 18 years old they are showing now
less amount of muscle mass and
resistance than 30 years ago and because
they don't move right right yeah I mean
that's yeah not surprised but it's super
high don't know that the the percentage
very super high it's like it's really
worrying so in this case I mean my
advice is like really focus on music and
try to I mean if you're a young musician
and you try to to please others first
that's that's all I mean you wanna play
music thinking that you need to be liked
by by others I don't think that's a good
idea you need to play what you really
feel it's good for you and not to copy I
mean it's good to learn from bands and
these covers and all that but then you
just try to do something different there
are so many but especially now it's
thousands and thousands of bands with
the same layout the same you know it's
and it's getting difficult it's more
difficult because that but at some point
I mean all of those bands a lot of those
bands they sound pretty similar yeah and
easier than ever to create harder than
ever to stand out and said but at the
same time the days of the massive
breakout you know hit machines are kind
of gone I mean everyone's you know
there's always a few but that's not what
it's about anymore it used to just be
about radio play and now look at the
career that you've carved out which is
very against the grain you know I don't
know that this career would be possible
30 years ago in the way that that it is
now and ever you know like my my 15 year
old daughter she she's constantly
discovering new music on soundcloud all
these on site like these are people no
one's ever heard of you know just really
and you can really create your nation
and I think it's that's exciting for
anybody who's interested in creating
because the tools are readily available
and the importance of the gatekeepers is
no longer yes yes yeah but you said like
we can say black or white there's a
benefits of all of the changes and also
ways it's always going to be good things
about the social media and how an artist
that is independent can take advantage
of all those things and all of that but
it's just more to balance thing yeah
yeah well I that's coming from that
experience of you that period where you
were trying to control everything right
now you like you have to be your own
social media manager and you have to do
your thinking about all these other
things other than the actual art itself
exactly so you yet you get to dispersed
your creativity everything because you
are thinking like like a few months ago
we got this call with our team and - we
never said oh you guys you need to do
social media blah blah blah we try it
got so distracted you know it was great
theater last night
that's what matters like for us we
realized the more we tried to be oh now
we're having a cup of tea is like all
right so what's up with the vegan thing
Oh what's yeah like what he tell me
about this okay
vegan when I start a little bit can I
start
yeah absolutely okay I was born
vegetarian my mom was the hippie she was
in this some sort of even via Hindus and
then me and my sister we were born
vegetarians and mostly into the vegan
thing that very healthy sort of thing
and then eventually I think was in
Ireland when I start to hear about vegan
and know what sawatya nice I didn't know
what it was
this is pre happy pair days right yeah
yeah and so our manager had shared a
flat with a vegan guy but he looked sure
I wanted to ask him well he looked he
looked angry and he had this dish energy
and I was asked because it it sounded
like he was gonna give me a bad time and
I didn't know why right a lecture is
coming I could something like I didn't
understand why the vegan grass honestly
I would try to ask my allure manager
what it is and it's like huh it's just
extreme and it was like yes but
okay so one day I'm in the restaurant
and the vegetarian restaurant I saw like
a pamphlet or something I did cornucopia
is great yeah yeah Dinka bean that's
right Gobi Desert okay
and they had this like it's a vegan sort
of propaganda thing and they talked
about how treatment of cows for dairy
and all of these things and for me was
at that time matoro but you train the
milk you don't hurt you don't care to
the cow you don't hurt the chickens and
in this thing it was just so clear and
for me was like ok that was it that was
it
and then one pamphlet a very effective
propaganda piece yes because for me was
it all my life since I was little girl
with me and my sister we wanted to - we
loved to be vegetarians we loved it
because with my mom instead of teaching
us how bad meat was she was more into oh
look at the beautiful animals oh look at
this beautiful tree and it was more
Intune inspiration side of things so for
us for both of us was always this
message but it was also very hard to
grow in Mexico which is it has a very
strong gastronomic culture and family
based culture and it was very strong for
us to be with her surrounded with all
these people and and have this
discrimination against us because it
wasn't like it wasn't a bad thing
they'd at least but all the jokes and
those kids are like give them grass and
then they say we're inside and all poor
little girls like so you don't need your
dreams inside like this we didn't care
because we ate so deliciously we never
felt we missed anything you know so for
me was easy to just flip into vegan
really quick I've traveled to a lot of
places all over the world and I've said
this before but the place that I had the
most difficulty eating vegan was Mexico
City yeah
and I did not expect that I thought
would be super easy to do it there now
he's getting I don't know when was last
time you went there it's it's incredible
in two years you know a happy cow that
that up man I used to be like three
restaurants now it's like yeah but like
if you go to a swanky restaurant
no kiddin like I just owe everything
would have some animal something yeah
that's what it makes
they put lard on it yeah you can't just
get beans on hard you know and they say
yeah but rot how did so how did this go
down I wasn't vegetarian until just
being around gap and gaps family
I saw them like they were very very very
healthy her and her sister and I just
suffer a lot like especially like yeah I
indigestion and all that like when I was
young and then I stopped eating red meat
when I was 16 mmm and I was like and I
kept doing the healthy according what
meat for years until early two-thousands
I there's a cat calm its BG and when all
the information started to come out and
YouTube you know was created and all
that
I saw him it's really one day and I look
into his eyes and I just you know you've
heard this story for Ryder just he gave
me the message the connection and I said
like that's the same and said you know
that chicken or the dog that I that I
eat and and that's it I really I changed
from zero to vegan in a moment and never
went back never miss like the cheese or
I didn't do it gradually like I turn
like in a second and that this song is
already like 12 years ago yeah that's
interesting yeah
so twelve years again you've longer
right no I think we both went vegan the
same time all right and now you guys are
in the midst of a tour I can't Akira cuz
you got to get down to San Diego you
know not only do you are you playing
these shows night after night after
night during the day you have to do
stuff like this it just monopolizes your
existence so before I let you go like
I'm just interested in how you maintain
balance and you know what is the
Wellness equation like meditation of
course we talked about that you guys are
eating vegan but what are the other
things that you do to make sure that you
are intact so that when you get up on
stage you can be like your best most
authentic self well lately for me I have
discovered that and I don't take life so
seriously you knows before I took life
super seriously so the stress the stress
can't it just burns you out completely
so I found that nowadays am more
energized because it's less of this
toxic stressful thoughts and all of this
worrying about things and it's just that
really really brings another level but
besides that yeah I like vegan food I'm
not so much into junk vegan although I
try it I'm so happy that people can
enjoy their favorite foods without
eating animals but I'm more into health
sort of juices and a lot of green tea
and I also exercise in them every
morning on tour go for a run - crazy as
he does but I do I run I do some yoga
and like real quick and and then I have
a green juice and we tend to eat very
the most healthy before like before
vegan I was not healthy I was vegetarian
but I loved wine and coffee and cheese
what she see were us and
ready Boris a lot of those things and
that doesn't help foreplay or beaten
sharp or anything like this
yeah well this is not very heavy metal
of you juice running yoga vegan
lifestyle but that's the new metal I
would say yeah little guys are doing
that yeah yes through heavy metal m ET t
and for me is the same I do a lot of
exercise I play soccer when I'm home
have my team their soccer well for you
to understand rage and take that
conversation and then I do yeah I we
tried to eat
yeah healthy I like of course I love
beyond burgers and I love you know but
in states is easy you go to Whole Foods
and you just massive salads you know
when we're on tour it's the easiest
thing yesterday to keep it in the side
and the healthy side and then I run I
like running and a lot and I tried to
especially not focus too much on tour
when we aren't or not to focus so much
on the fact that we aren't when we are
it's important to be very kind of
concentrated because we are doing that
but if you focus all your attention of
that then you get stressed you know it's
like a fog I mean I need to play a big
show tonight or whatever so we have
different projects gab has an amazing
cop in in in in CY like a non-profit
yeah that's not a cop it's not a profit
organization nonprofit
yeah yeah a little bit of that but is a
very community-based very is not fancy
or swanky we wanted to me and my sister
we wanted to share it with people who
has not access to information maybe to
access to food it's a little better in
Mexico especially good food in the sense
of fruits and vegetables would be far
more accessible because it's the price
is not as high as if you live in Germany
for instance but people wouldn't know
how to how to cooked or how to use all
those vegetables then over there but
they use a lot of oil and a lot of fried
tortillas that's what I love but it's
40% of the population in see what the
neighbor has diabetes so when it is very
hard so it's people like it and they
they have received it and we talked
about animals and all of that and they
go like some of them quite convinced but
we have to because these are our values
and that's the way we feel it should be
done yeah co-op that idea of having
something outside of your music yeah man
yeah for men yeah
for my reasons as well you need to to
just see to do other things not only for
that but financially it's a good idea
you know and I have a cafe restaurant in
Ixtapa a vegan cafe restaurant that my
girlfriend runs and it's called that
rice at a theatre which is cool it's a
nice place to go when I should work to
go I got I got a launch you guys out of
here
going up on my heels you got to get down
in San Diego so listen an honor and
privilege to talk to you guys thank you
so much we've spent some time with us
today your artistic expression is
beautiful it's touching so many people
and it was just a it was a thrill to be
there last night and see you guys do
what you do
thank you I honor you and have so much
respect not the same you're an
inspiration
thank you for dying to you really
everybody listening you got to check
these guys out if they if you want to
find tour dates just go to your website
right there we go Gabriela
you go to your Instagram page but you
won't see any pictures of you sipping
now this is art today I want you to take
a picture of you guys sipping espresso
[Laughter]
anyway come back to talk to me sometimes
yes thank you
much love peace
[Music]